tadwell golden Rainbow's annual ribbon
of Life Holiday Spectacular returns
again this weekend and not only is it a
great show it's also supporting a great
cause so here to tell us all about it we
have Gary Costa of golden rainbow and
Andrew Wright of ribbon of life you guys
thank you so much for being here thank
you for having us congratulations this
has been going on for 34 years right
that's so incredible I've been out a few
times to see the show but Gary I'll
start with you tell us a little bit
about Golden rainbow yeah we'll golden
rainbow we started back in the 80s when
people who were working on the Strip
were were dying of AIDS and so the
entertainment Community got together at
that time and put on a variety show that
raised lots of money for for housing and
um so as the pandemic continued they
continue to do the show and so here we
are in our 35th year and today our
golden rainbow provides housing for over
700 individuals wow well thank you for
everything that you all do in the
community and this show it's always so
much fun especially around the holidays
Andrew tell us a little bit about what
people can expect this weekend well it's
a great show what I love about it is you
have all of these different talents from
all of the shows and like you said it's
30 some odd years this is no city has
anything like it and so you have the
singers from Meet the meatloaf show that
just opened in Martinez and Travis
clover will be there we have Mario the
magician we have tape face so Headliners
from up and down the strip and of every
genre are coming together to lend their
talents and create a one-of-a-kind show
that you see once you can't go again
next time there's a ribbon of life it
will be totally different just to bring
in all different performers and
Headliners and how great does it feel to
have the support of them and the entire
Las Vegas Community oh it's it's
wonderful and they are the driving
course they started it this was not a
planned effort at the beginning it was
performers coming together and they have
been the heart for 30 plus years they
look forward to it it's a family reunion
really is what it is but just with very
talented family absolutely everyone is
so talented and everyone donates all of
their time everything for the producers
the directors every single person you
see on that stage is donating their own
time how cool and it's so fun to see it
come to life I've been year after year
it's always different always unique like
you said no show is the same so that's
really really special and obviously the
show is something we look forward to
every year but just overall how can
people get involved and help with golden
rainbow even when it's not the holiday
season sure you know we we always have a
smaller events and activities throughout
the year and then we also have volunteer
needs so they can just go to our website
at goldenrainbow.org and they can find
out more information there well that's
incredible and if people want to grab
some tickets I'm sure they're going
quickly but where can they get them this
weekend they can go to our website
goldrainbow.org or they also go to
Ticketmasters through the Tropicana
website well Gary Andrew thank you so
much for being here I'm really looking
forward to seeing this show this weekend
you guys always put on truly a
spectacular event so thank you for being
here all the information on your screen
the annual ribbon of Life Holiday
Spectacular it's happening Sunday
December 4th at the Legends and concert
theater at the Tropicana the website
there
goldenrainbow.org for tickets